now pay attention because I'm about to
tell you sick the guys ready the whole
damn thing is about choices excuse me
hey you're my new neighbor arches why
I'm Travis what are you so angry about
your dog knocked up my dog I take full
responsibility I've talked to him so
many times about using protection oh my
god okay no kidding I'm kidding I'm
kidding
hey big brother who's that what am I
gonna do with all you guys huh Thank You
Travis
I know that's the first time you said my
name
okay Travis this is Brian McCarthy my
boyfriend
alright I don't make a thing out of it I
don't know you and my big brother does
not like it and thinks I'm come easy I
have a confession
my friends like you bet and they like me
I was afraid that was gonna happen
are in so much more trouble and I don't
are you might be so hard for my flirt
with you if I'm a disease even up flirt
anymore
no what are you doing walking towards
you a little slow hi alright now that's
scary cuz you bother me don't tell him
we never talked about what this was it
just happened so fast we got caught up
oh well I don't live here oh ha she do -
mama knew with the second you set your
eyes on him whose side are you on anyway
Travis follow your pride because that's
all I need woman talks he's a man he's
gonna fight where's where's Carrie
she's gone where she left because of
huge blackouts and every path you take
leads to another choice to come father
made some choices to change everything
we should have a man it's not your fault
traps every moment of the rest of your
life hangs on
but they can just provide